this type of balance between
a pathogen and an immune system has been
shaped over thousands of years through
evolution
like natural selection all these type of
things what we have done here literally
is we have
thrown a bombshell
on this thing you know on this delicate
balance that has been established for
many many many years right
and
and then we
we would would we expect that this thing
is just going to die out it's not going
to have consequences or micronesia it's
the end of the pandemic phase as our
friend fauci is saying you know how can
you ever end the pandemic without
cutting dramatically the infection rate
what you are seeing right now is exactly
the opposite right
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast i am sitting as long time
viewers of dark horse will know with
gert vandenbosch who is a vaccinologist
and virologist
i talked to him on dark horse in geez
what month would that have been do you
remember garrett
um
i think it was
maybe
june
june
yeah that's quite possible
we talked about your hypothesis
regarding the impact of the mass
vaccination program against covid
uh on the pandemic and you said some
very
stark things about the likely outcome in
effect you described
the likely proliferation of escape
variants of the virus
and you implored us to stop the program
because you believed it would do more
harm than good i think we before we get
to your current view of the pandemic and
uh and the vaccination program let's
talk about how
uh
the
progress of the epidemic has matched
your expectations and in what ways it
might have departed from them yeah
well
first of all i think what i have been
predicting and
what uh
you know uh
was completely correct is that
by doing mass vaccination during a
pandemic that was my point
that we would drive
the
expansion the propagation of more
infectious variants
and i think
that evolution we have clearly seen we
have seen dominant propagation of you
know
alpha beta gamma delta omicron i think
the common denominator
was that each of these dominant variants
was more infectious than the previous
one
so back in those days i thought that
the higher level of infectiousness of
the virus would automatically imply
a higher level of
virulence or a higher level of damage
you know in terms of
the
incidence and maybe also of the severity
of the disease so let me just clear this
up for our viewers so you've got two
different parameters right one is how
transmissible it is and the other is how
harmful it is and so you can have a very
transmissible disease that can have a
very minor effect or you could have a
very transmissible disease in the worst
case that also was very harmful right or
you could have a very harmful disease
that didn't transmit very well all of
these are possible exactly exactly and
and
you know the harmfulness we call it
often the virulence right the uh the
capacity of the virus to cause you know
more severe or even deadly disease right
now i have to stop you there because
evolutionarily speaking it's confusing
to have these two terms because from the
viruses perspective the virulence is not
positive right it's
it's neutral or negative in general the
virus is only interested in propagating
and in general it is propagated best
when the creature that is infected is
most capable of walking around and
spreading it so
virulence is like a
an unavoidable downside of the the
pathogens mode of existence whereas
transmissibility is sort of the
objective of the exercise from the
evolutionary point of view is that fair
you understand yeah yeah the only thing
i'm always worrying about is that uh
people often especially virologists do
this they talk about the virus as if the
virus had a plan or
the the intrinsic properties of the
virus would be changing we we of course
often forget that when virus becomes you
know
causes less harm
that it is because the immunity of the
population is growing is keeping the
virus better and better under control
and that therefore so to say the virus
is becoming less harmful and less
infectious very often so that is
something which is very often
misunderstood people think you know the
virus uh you know wants to survive the
virus wants to do this no the virus has
no plan if all the virus can do is to
replicate well it can mutate and it can
hide in the genome but that is not
relevant for coronaviruses in this case
so i want to defend my language for a
second the problem with evolutionary
biology is if we speak in this ultra
rigorous way where we do not
imbue
a desire to propagate for example a plan
if we do not project that onto the virus
then we will have an impossible time
making any headway and so we speak with
a kind of shorthand and i i follow
dawkins in this regard where he says
it's just simply very important that any
time you make an argument that the you
know the the tree has grown tall in
order to shade the
the competitors right that you are able
to correct if you have to describe the
same thing in the perfectly rigorous but
not very useful terms you can do it
right you don't ever want to
to describe this in a way that you can't
you can't get back to the highly
rigorous version so
i think we have to use the shorthand
and
so it isn't you know obviously the virus
doesn't have a plan but it certainly
doesn't have an interest in doing harm
it is not served by doing harm
and what we are looking at is simply
that there are numerous copies of these
things i mean impossibly large numbers
of copies and those that happen to be
transmitted best are the ones that come
to dominate the population it's very
standard selection
selection
and um and so what that means is that
features that enhance the
transmissibility
are fostered sometimes those features
that enhance the transmissibility are um
a reduced virulence right that the
creature is more intact and therefore
the creature's ecology facilitates the
um the spreading
uh of the virus
so um so in that way
um i do think we have to be mindful of
this thing that the objective of the
virus is to transmit but the other thing
you said is very important which is that
and i remember learning this when i
studied immunology which is
that in general yes viruses do become
less virulent over time but the
evolution takes place on the part of the
host for the most part right which is a
disturbing discovery right because what
that means is that the virus is actually
exerting a selective effect on the host
right so in any case it's it's an
important point
but
so far i think what you've said
is that the vaccination program was
going to exert a selective pressure on
the virus that was going to cause a
proliferation of mutants that would be
that would have increased
transmissibility yeah a natural
selection of mutants that can overcome
that pressure and we put a pressure on
the spike protein obviously through the
antibodies and the spike protein is
responsible for infectiousness so we put
pressure on the infectiousness of the
virus so we got natural selection of
more infectious variants because the
more infectious variants obviously could
overcome the suboptimal pressure that we
put
on this characteristic of the virus
and the suboptimal pressure came of
course from the fact first of all you
put pressure by doing mass vaccination
and it is optimal because you do it
during a pandemic
so people get already exposed to the
virus before they have full-fledged
immunity
we do it in fact with prophylactic
vaccines that we use normally before we
get exposed to the virus when we travel
to a foreign country where we know there
is a disease we can protect against you
you make sure that you get you know your
full vaccination course completed before
you get exposed so we are not
quarantining people that we vaccinate
right they get a first shot
their antibodies are immature it takes
time for them to mount the antibodies
but at the same time the pandemic is
ongoing and they can get exposed and a
number of people get exposed while the
immunity is still suboptimal so the fact
the mass vaccination is one important
point and the other one do doing this
during a pandemic is also very very
important in terms of you know exerting
this suboptimal immune pressure so i
want to try to make that clear too
there's several errors here as i see it
you've listed two of them here
one of them is the mass vaccination
program and the other well actually
maybe
you've got mass vaccination
into a pandemic that's already raging
which means that there's several
different places where we now guarantee
evolution right
one of them
is that if you're just vaccinating
everybody you don't know who just caught
the virus at the moment you vaccinate
them who's about to catch the virus and
so what that means is you know immunity
takes time to develop the immune system
is learning something and it actually
learns this through an amazing process
one of my favorite facts in all of
biology is clonal selection right
because we are a static target that
lives for
80 90 years and we are up against
pathogens that evolve on the scale of
hours
we have a population of cells that have
been
adjusted by evolution
to evolve in the same time scale i find
that
just an utterly stunning fact right so
we have these cells b and t cells being
uh the examples so b cells make
antibodies t cells have something like
antibodies that never leaves the cell
it's not a free-floating
protein
but the process of clonal selection
requires cells to produce cells to
produce cells and each
generation of those cells gets closer to
the formula which means there's a period
of time over which your immunity is
developing and the problem is that that
period of time over which the immunity
is developing may interface with a
pathogen that is so widespread that you
are likely to get it and at the point
that your immune system is exerting this
selective pressure before you've
developed immunity is you have partial
immunity partial immunity is like a
training program for the virus yeah and
that is really the key error
am i right absolutely yeah that is that
is really the key the key error and i'm
always comparing this to you know it's
just so amazing to me that
everybody knows this from the field of
antibiotics
and
the only difference is we all know that
viruses depend on living cells
and but if you have a bacterium for
example and you have a medium with a sub
optimal concentration of an antibiotic
the bacteria they can replicate on
themselves so there is no cha no no need
to change the medium you have the
suboptimal concentration of the
antibiotic and then you have the
bacterium and of course you will have a
selection of mutants that can overcome
this you know this hostile environment
if now we have like viruses that you
know depend on living cells and of
course they will destroy the cell so
they will come out of the cell so with
that
also you know when they get transmitted
for example to another individual it is
very very important that you keep that
suboptimal medium this support
if if the virus gets transmitted to
somebody who is not vaccinated
this person is not going to present that
hostile environment to the virus and you
got the natural selection in one person
but that advantage gets lost if it is
transmitted to somebody who does not
have this optimal immunity but if you do
the mass vaccination it's like this
suboptimal medium is going to be
conserved just like with you know the
bacterium because it gets transmitted to
somebody else but in the same situation
because this person also is presenting
this optimal immunity and if you have
like 60 70 of the population in that
situation you will of course you will
promote this natural selection and
enrich of course this varied in the
population so it is largely
largely comparable to the situation with
bacteria and suboptimal antibiotics just
that the virus depends on a living cell
and you know it needs to be transmitted
to perpetuate its its cycle but every
single time in a massively vaccinated
population it will encounter the same
medium just like the bacterium is
proliferating in under hostile
conditions of suboptimal antibiotic
concentration right so
uh
in effect
what we did which you're pointing out is
we ran
an insanely large gain of function
experiment that we didn't mean to run
we set up a selective environment and we
basically said
here is the here here are the tools that
we are going to deploy against you in a
very weakened form and that gave the
virus the ability to you know experiment
in the way natural selection does and
discover vulnerabilities of that system
but your point is it goes from one
person to another person and it keeps
finding people with the sub-optimal
immunity so it keeps finding the same
puzzle again and again and again it's
going to get good at it and there's
another flaw here which
arguably
maybe they didn't know i i suspect they
did but the fact that these vaccines are
well and we probably should not be
calling them vaccines robert malone
scolded me about that uh
earlier and i believe i believe he's
right i i at first wasn't convinced that
the terminology mattered but this is
sufficiently novel
that um we should probably use a
different term but these inoculations
do not produce sterilizing immunity and
that's the point of course so
on the one hand even if they did produce
sterilizing immunity you've got a
problem if you're vaccinating into the
face of the pandemic because people on
the way to having full immunity are
still again a function experiment
effectively but in this case even people
who have reached the final stage haven't
encountered the pathogen have had two
weeks or a month to develop their
immunity are still a gain of function
experiment because the immunity isn't
sterilizing meaning they can catch the
virus and they can transmit it it's not
shutting down the virus in their system
is that fair yeah yeah the problem is
you know from the very beginning i i
that that's what i said don't use these
vaccines that do not induce sterilizing
immunity
during a pandemic and in the form of
mass vaccination so these three elements
are or absolutely you know critical
and uh there is very often some
misunderstanding about this sterilizing
immunity because uh imagine if you would
get you know vaccinated by a vaccine
that induces antibodies
only antibodies and you would have you
know a full-fledged vaccination course
so you have you end up with high titles
of antibodies
and i would say when the antibodies
reach the peak
when at that very moment you get exposed
to the pathogen there is a reasonable
likelihood depending of course on the
viral load that all of the virus you got
exposed to get neutralized by these
antibodies and then people say well you
see there is neutralize there is
sterilizing immunity
at that point the vaccine induces
sterilizing immunity but if you would
you know have the same encounter with
the same exposure at the point in time
where the antibodies would already be
declining or whether the antibodies
would still be very high but you would
have a much higher viral load than the
quantity the concentration of the
neutralizing antibodies would never that
does not suffice to completely
neutralize the virus and then the very
same vaccine against the very same
disease would not induce sterilizing
immunity you see so that is that is
important to understand that is the the
disadvantage of the antibodies of of
protection that relies completely on
antibodies right and actually that's the
next thing i was going to say is that
one of the things that has been very
clear
uh in
the
very confused informational environment
that we have faced is that there's
almost an obsessive focus
on antibodies and i almost feel like
that is driven by the fact that the
public knows that term and has some
relationship with the idea of an
antibody but they don't have a
relationship with
the other types of immunity t-cell
immunity for example is is playing such
a strong role and really
my understanding and you know you're the
vaccinologist but a vaccine that induced
a durable t-cell immunity would be much
more effective in this battle and it
wouldn't you wouldn't necessarily be
able to read that it was there in the
antibodies because frankly if even if
the response was entirely on the t cell
side and therefore you didn't see an
antibody titer it would still
potentially be very effective now it is
likely that you would have an antibody
response that you can easily measure and
a t cell response which is much more
difficult to measure yeah is that fair
yeah yeah but you know unfortunately
none of these vaccines none of these
vaccines are inducing
a sterilizing t cell response
that has memory so you can induce t
cells but if you don't have memory it's
not going to help you because that's the
purpose of course of vaccines that the
next time around the immune system would
remember this so none of the vaccines
but even during natural immunity there
is no evidence there is plenty of
publications on t cells with coronavirus
but there is no single evidence there is
no single study
that shows that you have cytolytic t
cells so t cells that can effectively
kill a virus infected cells and that
have memory
induced by natural natural infection so
this is very typical for coronavirus
also for enterovirus and what happens
most likely is that because when you get
a disease you recover from the disease
you know some people recover after three
four five days
that is much shorter than it takes for
developing the kind of antibodies we
were talking about you're just talking
about you know before you get this
maturation isotype switching etc it
takes several weeks sometimes so the
question is how then can you recover
from the disease after three four days
and if this would be memory t cells
then you would expect that next time
around you you know
you are completely protected against
against the disease so what we know is
that there are
um
epitopes
in this spike protein
that we call them they are universal
they are completely conserved
and
they induce cytotoxic t cells but that
have no memory
so that means if you get infected
and the virus will be presented of
course by antigen presenting cells
because it's a foreign body it will be
you know presented by antigen-presenting
cells that is the purpose that is the
goal of the you know the objective of
those cells
that then this universal epitopes so it
means that regardless of your genetic
background you know you notice the mhc
complex
it is not restricted by the genetic
background so it works in in everyone
but it it binds with very very high
affinity to these mhc complexes and that
induces the cytotoxic t cells but
without memory so you will cure out a
disease you will eliminate
you know device affected cells but there
is no memory if there were memory
because it's a universal epitope
you would expect that whatever corona
virus you have been infected before
would be completely protective because
you would have
long lived
cytotoxic t cells that would be even you
know if you have induced memory even
five years ten years
later
they can still be recalled and do the
job and that is not the case and that is
a big misunderstanding many people have
been saying yeah previous coronavirus
protect you
and etc of course they can to some
extent protect you but they are not
recalling
previously
induced memory t cells because they
don't exist they don't exist
yeah you will have memory t cells that
will produce produce cytokines that of
course plenty of cytokines and the
cytokines can dampen the infection and
the disease but
there is no study whatsoever whether it
is with the vaccines or
or as a consequence of natural disease
that has been able to demonstrate
the presence of the induction i should
say of cytotoxic
t cells memory t cells
that work universally in everybody and
that's what you need for a vaccine
because you know that is the reason that
why
up till today we don't have vaccines
that are based on t cell immunity of
course t helper cells also if you if you
don't have the t helper cells you don't
have good antibodies but in order to
have you know the problem with the t
cells is that
same as with the antibodies but is the
other way around the problem of the
antibodies is the antigen variability
that's what we are seeing right now that
you know the virus the fact that the
antibodies that are in use by
the vaccine do no longer match with the
circulating kind but with regard to the
t cells we have another limitation which
is the the the restriction by the
genetic background your mhc complex is
different from mine and of course if you
come with a t-cell vaccine with certain
epitopes these epitopes by your genetic
background your mhc aprotypes will be
presented in a way that you induce maybe
cytolytic t cells but it will not be the
case you know with myoplotyps because
the same epitopes that are in the
vaccine or not will not be presented in
an immunodominant way so see that is
where we have severe limitations also
with regard to t cell vaccines well up
till today we don't have realities we
don't have any vaccines that eliminate
or that abrogate infection yeah
abrogation because the cell should be
first infected and then you could kill
the virus infected cells so this
abrogation of of the infection that's
also the reason why we don't have
therapeutic vaccines because it means
that the cell is already infected can
you then abrogate can you stop the
infection can you kill the virus
infected cell no we don't have those so
that is something which is um very
important to know because people still
think well you know we we are focusing
this on the spy pro protein we should
have had you know more t cells uh you
know yeah you can induce plenty of t
cells but if these t cells are not
capable of to your point
killing virus infected cells and when
you kill the cell since the virus needs
to rely on a living cell if you kill the
cell that it infected it cannot
propagate anymore right so that is
sterilizing immunity as well right it's
it's not by neutralizing
all the virus particles before they can
enter into the cell it's so once they
enter you you let them enter into the
cell as many as possible and then you
come in you say you know what my
criterium is i'm going to kill literally
every single cell that got infected that
is also sterilizing the other i
distinguish very often between sterile
immunity
where you prevent infection from taking
place by neutralizing all the viral
particles you know before they can enter
into the cell in the first place
compared to sterilizing immunity you
allow the invasion into the cell but
once the cell is is infected you're
gonna kill the whole thing right it's
sterilizing immunity that's a very good
distinction i've never heard that one
before yeah exactly is that yours
yeah well i i don't know but i've taken
this you know
you know vaccinology has been confronted
with so many shortcomings we have no uh
you know and and people are asking why
do we have all these limitations why can
we not i mean there's so many things but
you know
when you have an antibiotic we think
it's it's completely logical
that you can
kill several different bacteria even if
phallogenetically they are completely
unrelated everybody thinks this is very
normal
and with vaccines with antibodies or
with immunity we are can you believe it
we are if if there is an antigenic shift
or an antigenic drift
we have already a problem look at the
influenza vaccine you know every year we
need to do an update and and very often
we calculate so we have this severe
restrictions so that is also genetic hiv
all these chronic diseases we have no
vaccines against us we have been
testing we have been trying for 20 years
to make a vaccine against hiv for
example we have been failing and
therefore i've been deeply involved when
i was working at the billion melinda
gates foundation because they're
essentially concentrating on very
difficult diseases that become chronic
tuberculosis malaria hiv
so yes i've taken a very very deep dive
into this because people have been
trying to solve this with achievements
with new delivery technologies etc right
and and yeah so we have turned it upside
down in all and that is where you get i
think quite deep insight into you know
the limitations of current vaccinology
it's like the difference between fusion
and fission power fission isn't that
hard fusion turns out to be incredibly
difficult to get right
that i'm just familiar with well let me
ask you this i i take your comparison
between bacteria where we can have an
antibiotic that is broadly effective
against bacteria from different clades
and we just consider that normal and
your comparison to vaccines which you
know you make a vaccine that works and
then a slight antigenic shift makes it
yeah
why the distinction so i'm going to
guess the distinction is actually the
reason that viruses are what they are
right viruses have gotten
a huge
evolutionary benefit
from shedding all of their biology and
borrowing it from their host right
because what it does is it reduces the
attackable architecture right because
the art the architecture is you right so
in effect what you have are antigens
right and the point is those are
amenable to being shifted out from under
whatever you point at them so that's
sort of a a built-in problem it's a
reasonable yeah it's a building problem
yeah a built-in problem i also wanted to
go back and just
point out that your your example of a
medium with sub-optimal amounts of
antibiotic really makes this point and
you can imagine
if you throw
bacteria on a medium that has twice as
much antibiotic twice the concentration
necessary to kill it well then no
individual survives so there is no next
phase of the experiment and the problem
is that selection gets very effective
when
something lives and it almost becomes i
mean it really is more effective if you
really bottleneck something down to a
very the most you know unique members of
the population
then the next uh iteration is entirely
born of those unique members of the
population so you've done a very
effective job of finding the ones who
are resistant so um so
we have this issue
and then i would add
uh to the issue of vaccinating into the
uh pandemic
the non-sterilizing immunity creating a
gain of function experiment even in
people who've developed their full
immunity there's also the issue that
this extremely novel mechanism for
delivering a vaccine has narrowed what
the immune system is exposed to
so much that it actually makes a much
easier puzzle for selection to solve
right i i have not really heard this
discussed anywhere maybe i've been
missing it but
if you
use let's say you used a
a live attenuated virus or a killed
virus right but the whole virus
then you get antibodies to various
different uh epitopes right you get
you'd get some uh antibody to the spike
you get some to the nucleocapsid
and the point is this let's say that
you're vaccinated with such a thing
right now you have memory cells
that are producing several different
types of antibodies
if some virus figures out if it makes a
mu if it has a mutation that allows it
to escape the immunity that was
generated to one of those antigens it
doesn't necessarily create an advantage
because as long as the antibodies to the
other antigens still
manage to effectively shut down the
virus the point is that successful
change doesn't get transmitted and so i
think there's another mistake here which
is that to use one antigen
means that there's no failsafe and that
effectively the more antigens your body
knows the formula to the less the chance
that any innovation that would defeat
one of them actually lives to pass on
the information
is that fair
yeah well
no it's not fair in this case because of
course this was this is the argument
that immediately comes up and that we
have been you know we
we have heard this so many times that
you know what is the problem of the
antigen because as you're pointing out
you're just using one antigen but
then i'm saying you know what is the
what is the benefit of
an antigen of having antibodies
uh induced against an antigen that first
of all is not
accessible
to the antibodies like the nuclear
capsule in mind it's not except
accessible because it's blocked by all
the squares on the surface and and as
you're pointing out what is the critical
thing it is
the
the protein that enables the infection
into the cell you know
that is the one you you you have to
target which is why they picked it yeah
of course so i do think it is the right
target but if you put it on the immune
pressure and i i
you know i bet whatever you want
you can come with plenty of other
antigens you're of course you're going
to induce many many antibodies but they
are not going to prevent the infections
in your virus because they are directed
against
proteins you know that are not involved
into viral injury that
will also to a large extent not be
accessible to
the antibodies because they are inside
of the you know they are not presented
necessarily on the membrane to sell
well okay maybe you just answered my
question but doesn't this raise your
distinction between sterile immunity and
sterilizing was that you know for me the
sterile
sterile immunity but that is a
definition that i'm just to distinguish
because i think we need to distinguish
between a situation where antibodies in
exceptional situations as i was
explaining if you are really uh you know
boosting somebody you have high titles
of antibodies and at the peak of their
antibodies you are exposing them to a
mild viral load you may be in the
exceptional situation at that very point
where you have reached the peak that the
antibodies would be able to neutralize
all the virus so that none of the
particles can even enter into the cell
sterilizing immunity is once this
process has happened you the the virus
has already invaded the cell so it's no
longer a sterile situation but you can
make it sterile again by killing it by
effect
sure right but doesn't that solve the
problem of let's say the nuclear capsid
proteins not being available to the
antibodies because the infected cell
will still
indicate that it is infected and so you
can't generate the sterilizing immunity
that prevents the invasion of the cell
but you could have an effective response
that would kill all of the infections
that i agree with but then then we
should be able that's what i'm saying we
should be able
to generate vaccines
that for because in the infected cell of
course i mean these proteins these other
proteins that are hidden
in the uh in the virus in the complete
before it gets into the cell when it
gets into the cell several different
viral proteins that are normally hidden
within the viral particle will be
presented on the membrane of the
infected cell but then you should be
able and that is what i'm saying that
current vaccinology is not capable of
doing it you should be able to induce
cytolytic t t-cells that are specific
let's say for example the nucleocapsids
okay
that are antigen specific nucleocapsids
specific and that are capable of
inducing antigen-specific
cytolytic because they need to kill the
cell t-cells and they need to have
memory because if you get vaccinated and
it's not memorized and it and it needs
to be
in order to be a vaccine that is useful
in a universal way if it works with your
mhc complex but not with mine
you have the restriction right i mean we
we have we have done all this homework
right i mean and that is what i'm saying
even during natural infection with
coronaviruses same with enteroviruses
nobody nobody has ever demonstrated
that there is even through natural
disease induction of universally you
know functional
cytolytic memory t cells that are
antigen specific right you have plenty
of memory t cells that will produce
cytokines and of course they can
modulate they can they can of course
mitigate the disease and all these type
of things but if you want to have
sterilizing immunity that's our point
and certainly during a pandemic you need
to be able for god's sake to to kill
that cell right
oh yes 100 yeah okay let's get out of
the weeds because i have a feeling we
will have lost some people let's uh
let's bring them back no that's not your
fault um
all right so we have a vaccination
program and a
an inoculation
that is effectively effectively creates
an inadvertent gain of function
experiment where we are setting up the
hurdles for the virus to solve this
problem evolutionarily and to re-emerge
on the basis of the alteration of the
spike protein which is the only protein
we targeted
all right
so that
last time we spoke you said this is
going to produce escape
variants that that's what we should be
looking for and you believed that we
were going to see escape variants that
were both more infectious and more
virulent is that right
yeah
i i was in fact not distinguishing that
much at that point between you know the
higher level of virulence and
infectiousness i
almost thought you know when the virus
is going to become highly infectious
that was really my conviction
then
automatically is going to split much
faster and doing much more harm in the
population
so
so that has come out i guess i think
everybody acknowledges that this mass
vaccination now
has a
uh promoted i should say the expansion
of highly infectious variants i've never
been saying that the mass vaccination
induces the mutations because of course
mutations
but it enables the virus you know to do
a natural selection between all the
different mutants that are produced
anyway and to select those that are most
appropriate to overcome this pressure
you know on on the infectiousness of the
virus this is to say we'll select the
more infectious variants and enable
those to become to the system that we
discuss the mass vaccination the same
medium everywhere to become predominant
of course in the population
so
that is true but
at the same time and that is probably
maybe the next question you want to ask
it did not automatically on the contrary
in fact imply a higher level of
virulence so that is why it's something
that i also
learned that
and that is also why i'm saying it's not
the end of the story there will be a
second step that a virus will take if we
continue you know
well continue mass vaccination by for
example vaccination vaccinating children
or by boosting people and boosting
people is like an automatic process we
have omicron circulating that is far
more you know stronger as a boost than
coming with the new omicron vaccine for
example right
yes well it does raise the question and
i think many of us have scratched our
heads over it why we are still
transfecting people with
wuhan
version spike protein why has the i mean
if there's one
there are so many downsides to the way
they chose to vaccinate here if there's
one upside is that you could swap out
the antigen that you've targeted for an
updated version without changing
anything else
and yet we haven't updated this which is
an odd fact um do you have an
interpretation
why why nevertheless they continue why
did they why are they still recommending
boosters with the original version of
the spike protein rather than an updated
one well you know brett it's it's it's
interesting that even in
you know
2022 where we have all this access
to
you know signs and technologies that
vaccinology has remained an extremely
empirical thing
and as a matter of fact and the answer
is as easy as that
they continued and they found out well
you know i mean seems like the efficacy
is going down
but for some reason for some reason this
thing believe it or not still seems to
protect against severe disease
so now i'm asking you
do you know about any vaccine any
vaccine
that in fact makes even the vaccinee
more susceptible to infection
right and nevertheless protects against
severe disease
do you know any vaccine that does not
protect against disease but that
protects against severe disease so it's
not a logical approach but as a matter
of fact they continue and they find out
even if the duration of that protection
even against severe disease is declining
everything is declining initially we had
an impact on transmission then that was
no longer the case we had an impact on
disease no longer the case we had only
an impact on severe disease for a
duration of a couple of months now we
have impact for a few weeks on severe
disease right and so empirically they
say you know
we in fact what they're saying is we
don't understand how this works i'm just
telling you i don't know after all these
years of vaccinology i don't know of any
vaccine that has these characteristics
protects only against severe disease not
against disease it enhances even the
susceptibility of the vaccines to
infection nevertheless they are
protected against severe disease right
well yeah how convinced are you that
that work
is to be taken at face value
because i've seen at least one analysis
that suggests it may not be a robust
fact no i agree with you that it's not
robust that's why i'm saying it's it's
oh so you're saying this is suspicious
oh yeah absolutely all right
yes okay this is really remarkable okay
yeah well remarkable no it is suspicious
but you're asking me why they're still
con
continuing this and i'm i'm i'm
answering you it's an empirical business
right and and and they
found out that you know it's still
protecting against severe disease so
they're saying you know let's continue
with this one well maybe i understand
why they're continuing the vaccination
campaign because unfortunately it would
appear to be a a straight-up business
decision right that they
are obsessed with putting more vaccines
in more arms i can say there's a
straight obviously they're being paid on
a per-vaccination
basis at some level so they have that
interest i think they also have a
perverse interest in getting rid of the
control group because yeah there's so
much of course an adverse
signal adverse event signal so anyway
there are lots of reasons they seem to
want to vaccinate people but i'm not
yeah i'm what i'm curious about is why
as long as they were going to do this
they didn't update
the antigen and i can think of i can
think of a business reason that they
might have you know there's this funny
business around
the uh
emergency use authorization came with
special liability protections they then
got fda approval but they are still
delivering the emergency use authorized
version even though they are supposed to
be essentially the same why are they
doing that because it preserves their
special protection from liability maybe
if they updated the antigen under the
fda approved version they would lose
that so i could imagine that that would
be the case yeah it would also take time
they know that the antibodies as you
know are directed against the receptor
binding domain which has a high level of
variability and i think the main
criterion for the public health daughter
authorities is is to keep the
hospitalizations under control
and that is so to say what a vaccine
according to them still does because
they are just looking at what is
happening today they are not interested
in the evolution they are not interested
in seeing what is happening tomorrow
what is going to happen in a few months
from now and so they are making these
snapshots okay what are the number of
hospitality we continue with this
vaccination okay infectious rates go
through the roof it's the first time
that we see see all this is very
suspicious is the first time that we see
that the morbidity and mortality rate is
no longer following the infection rate
during natural epidemic is the following
now it's completely disconnected right
and
but they're saying you know don't care
don't care because we still have the
hospitalizations under control right so
there's no need for you know for an
update or whatever right right where
one of the things that i i don't want to
get us too far off track but one of the
things that i've been of course
wondering about is um
what i see
is that we did
essentially the inverse of what we
should have done on every front i would
flip almost every bit the opposite
direction yeah i i agree none of the
things that have been done make any
sense
it could be scientifically justified
right
so and and to me this is very alarming
because you can get incompetence can
give you something like a random
response it can't give you the inverse
of a great response right that's
something else so
we can leave that uh b for the moment
but um
so i have this question in my mind
though
let's say that we you know just the
thought experiment suppose that we
hadn't
done the mass vaccination
campaign yeah right and then there's
sort of two versions of that okay let's
say we did nothing and we just
behavioral modifications and nothing
else what would the world look like
today how much loss of life would there
have been and then the second version of
it the one that i would favor and i
think you would favor
is
without the vaccination program and the
aggressive development of protocols
based largely around interventions that
are known to work supplementing vitamin
d for people who are deficient
reproductive drugs
absolutely early treatments
hydroxychloroquine iron the other stuff
that seems to be so effective
where would we be today if we had done
the a and b versions of the don't don't
use these vaccines what do you think
well first of all for me it's it's you
know i i cannot i can simply not imagine
because people are always saying yeah
you're saying stop mass vaccination what
would you do you know let people die no
of course not we have these you know
treatments and it's not that these
treatments were new
some people have started early on like
peter mccullough etc showing that this
was really very effective and as you
know i i'm coming from the veterinary
field what you often what you sometimes
do with certain diseases
you would infect the animal deliberately
and then you would treat the animal
so in that way you can immunize
so if somebody in other words gets the
disease
and you do the early treatment of course
also with the animal you will not wait
till till it it's moribund right
so you will treat
then this you know they will recover
from the disease automatically they will
build antibodies they will contribute to
her immunity right
and of course is also this thing about
you know all the other age groups i mean
you know the elderly of course they
would have had to intervene also people
with underlying diseases
comorbidities we know the groups the
vulnerable groups
all the other age groups i mean of
course they could have had some
asymptomatic some mild or moderate
disease
but what is wrong with getting the
disease and being in bed for a couple of
days right we
you recover from this
it then
provides a large part of the population
with immunity with herd immunity once
this hurt immunity is established it
means that the likelihood that somebody
who is vulnerable who has a weak
innate a
weak immune system
gets infected with a viral load that
would be sufficient to make that person
ill is very very remote in other terms
once you reach that third immunity
you don't you can you can just you know
skip all the infection prevention
measures etc that you had put in place
during the time where hurt immunity was
in the process of being built up in
order to protect these people right that
is what would
would some people have died of course
right but the pandemic you know i mean i
can only that's also something which is
very stunning to me astonishing that
if you are confronted with a pandemic i
mean our generation has never seen this
the first thing to do is you look what
happened in history you know what
happened with the spanish flu for
example how long did that last i've been
checking all the pandemics that have
been documented none of them lasted
longer than 18 months for example right
so and and some of them you know eight
or ten months now you have to realize
back in those days you know the the
world was still a very large
place it took time you know because
people you know we're not that
interconnected etc now but now the world
has become a very small place so i even
suspect that
absolutely absolutely right so this this
this match is this matches my
uh sense of where we'd be if we had done
nothing
it would have there would have been a
massive loss of life it would have
it would have burned itself out and we
would be lamenting the loss of life but
we'd be effectively done with it if we
had done the right thing which is to
skip the transfection campaign
and to aggressively use the tools that
uh quickly became apparent that they
worked for the vulnerable population
yeah yes well
really i mean we've seen examples where
these things have been deployed well
like uttar pradesh for example yeah
probably japan although it's a little
harder to figure out what they need in
japan it's we can discuss this but i
have uh you guys i have a lot of uh very
uh strong information you know first
trustworthy information from really
inside there's not curious it's not
either making that decision
but they are talking rather about uh you
know the uh
tb uh vaccines still being part of the
childhood vaccination program
and you have heard about these studies
where you know a lot of immunity gets
stimulated by the tb uh vaccine and and
they are saying it's rather due to this
to this fact rather than to the eye from
acting but okay but anyway
so
if we had treated aggressively
protected the vulnerable
prophylactically maybe we protected
everybody prophylactically in light of
the uh fact that ivermectin worked that
way in at least the initial variance i
mean one of the things that troubles me
here is that ivermectin's efficacy has
dropped
right i actually didn't expect that but
it did since
when did it drop delta
delta and omicron right yeah so
i think i have an explanation for this
but we can come back to this
but you you can keep it in mind yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah
uh i'm very curious i don't know why you
are interested yeah but uh okay but um
but in any case i do think that we have
these two other scenarios both of them
are better than where we are
we had we've had very high loss of life
and we've had uh
basically a um
a collapse in
our belief in our medical apparatus
because it has revealed itself to be
incompetent at protecting us and it has
revealed that it's willing to lie
egregiously in all of this so yeah all
the collateral damage and bread it's not
finished well and it's not finished
which is really conspicuous because
and this this has been bugging me for
for a year now which is you know we look
at these rates right and you know the
rate is rising it's rising in a
population more than half of which has
already had the virus so the point is we
are not seeing the accumulation of the
immunity that would normally be
accompanying anything like this and
we're seeing
such rapid proliferation of these
variants you know and we're seeing
people get the disease multiple times
within months of each other
there's a lot here that's non-standard
and
you know we will of course never know
what would have happened if we had
behaved in one of these other ways but
i'm i'm
reassured to hear that you you see
something of the same picture absolutely
absolutely i mean what is also very
interesting is
you know
they have been doing analysis pcrs on
corpses from people who died from this
spanish flu back into it and and they
have
pretty compelling evidence
that there has not been you know a shift
in
variance right during that epidemic yeah
right so
yeah so the the the the the the variant
or the lineage that basically you know
caused or was was was there at the
beginning of the pandemic was still the
same that entered into endemicity right
right but this is this is i well you
tell me if i've got it wrong but this is
what i'm saying about
if you have
multiple antigens and the body has
responded to them then it is much harder
to solve the problem of escape for the
virus escaping the immunity if the
immunity is multifaceted it's much
harder because even if
the even if some virus comes up with the
perfect solution for one antigen
it still doesn't escape because the
other antigens shut it down yeah but
it's infectious is that that colon so i
will tell you what the reason is if you
have
natural immunity and we are not talking
about mass flask back back in the
spanish flu
so what happens is that
i was just
talking about you know the cytotoxic t
cells for example the same with
influenza
that have no memory but they will they
will kick in pretty fast they will you
know take out the majority of the viral
load
and by the time your antibodies start to
rise
most of the viral load will already be
cleared
so you're not mounting antibodies in the
presence of the virus
which
you know is of course avoiding immune
escape
that is so important to understand
because that is very different from a
situation where people get immunized and
then get you know exposed to sometimes a
high viral load
you know
that is what what what is so frustrating
when people
compare
vaccine-induced immunity and
natural
naturally induced immunity they only
look at the antibodies and the capacity
of the antibodies but they forget
that
before getting acquired antibodies as a
result from the disease that the virus
first need to break through
the previous stages of the immunity for
example the cytotoxic t cells right and
the training of innate immune systems
right and that that is also that that
you cannot analyze this you know the
cytotoxic t cells that have no memory
you know normally you re-stimulate in
vitro with peptides but if there is no
memory you cannot really stimulate this
trained innate immunity we have no tools
to examine this so we are only looking
at part of the natural immune defense if
we look at the naturally acquired
antibodies and compare those to the
vaccine-induced antibodies right so we
the the natural immunity in other words
is much more powerful and the part that
we are analyzing and comparing to the
vaccine-induced immunities which uh
vaccine-induced antibiotics which do not
you know go through these previous
stages of immunity this is completely
unfair right and that the system is so
sophisticated you as an evolutionary
biologist should be very interested into
is that in fact in fact you know by the
fact that most of the viral load gets
taken out by the cytotoxic t cells which
are not you know
they are not
very specific so they are not leading to
natural selection
and by the time you reach the peak of
the antibodies that takes time most of
the viral load has already disappeared
so there is no pressure on the viruses
no immune escape right it's extremely
interesting so you need all these data
i'm always saying if you study this
phenomena you cannot afford to
leave any zone unturned you have to ask
all the questions why why why why and
unless you have
an answer to all of the questions
you cannot you know
draw conclusions and certainly not
extrapolate to you know this is the same
as with the vaccine
antibodies or antibodies acquired
antibodies or required antibodies yeah
you understand what i'm saying oh i i do
and it is it is a classic mistake when
people with some other kind of expertise
walk into a complex system
a complex system requires that you have
humility about what you don't know which
is almost everything i like
that's work yeah yes it's it's really
important and i must say uh
in speaking to you the first time
uh you certainly opened my eyes to what
was right in front of me and i wasn't
seeing it which was the
implication
of
so many people who had never been
exposed to this pathogen who weren't
vulnerable to it right that they had a
completely effective response on board
now it does leave me with the next
question
which is
whatever that innate immunity is
why does it decay so rapidly in life
right i know a lot about senescence this
surprises me quickly in the innate
immunity why does it decay well i know
why it decays i don't understand why it
decays so precipitously
well i i'm not sure that it's true
provided the innate immunity gets
strained right you know this is
something which has been pretty well
described essentially over the last 10
years that through epigenetic changes
you get it's not a classical memory
where you have a memory marker but the
epigenetic changes
will lead to a kind of functional
reprogramming of cells
so that when they produce the antibodies
next time around they will you know
better recognize the pathogen okay so
then what you're telling me i think i
get it but i don't know it so uh
help me out here
a five-year-old
has pretty good innate immunity to covid
because their system has not been
programmed too very much because it has
not encountered very much the more of
that system that you narrow into some
into responding to some pathogen that
the child encounters the less of it is
available for general use is that what's
going on that this is a trade-off as you
get specific you lose the general
yeah
yes
i mean it's uh it's taking a few
shortcuts but i mean that is certainly
the way to explain it to the audience
okay
to me and in fact
that would not at all be a problem
if the narrow targeting which has high
specificity for example in form of you
know
adaptive antibodies right if it was
targeted at covid but it's not right so
i get this now so basically the point is
you've got some beautiful system that
could in principle see anything and it
will see a bunch of things and the point
is it can't do that forever and so that
i never understood this before and this
has been a key feature this has been one
of the things that people don't
understand about your model and i'm not
saying that i understand whether your
model is right or wrong but when people
talk when sophisticated people talk
about garrett vandenbosch and his view
they say why is he so focused on the
innate immunity and these peculiarities
of it
and um
i think this is a pretty satisfying
answer right
the effectiveness of an untrained immune
system against covid is shockingly good
yes but the only limitation is is
because of the affinity of these
antibodies is lower yeah they interact
what they recognize in fact
are patterns
on the surface of the virus on the
surface of the cells
patterns
and that is the beauty of the system
that patterns this
most likely glycan patterns are shared
amongst the broad spectrum of different
viruses not only all the variants of
sarsko v2 but all the corona viruses
most likely all the glycosylated
envelope viruses like even influenza etc
but because they bind through
multivalent binding
their affinity because in that case you
talk about avidity of the antibody
responses
so they have the strength of binding is
you know
inferior to the strength of binding of
specific antibodies so you could say
well we do this all the time when we
vaccinate our childhood vaccinations for
example but you know there is no problem
as you were pointing out if the specific
antibodies that you induce do a perfect
job because they have memory they have
strong affinity that means they will
strongly neutralize
the innate antibodies they are perfect
but they cannot cope with a high viral
load
but if you break through that innate
immunity you will have the phenomenon
that we were just describing you will
get acquired antibodies and guess what
these acquired antibodies will be a
perfect match to the virus that cause
the disease
whereas now we are with the wuhan
the spike is not at all a good fit
obviously to the virus we are
so you see how powerful this natural
immunity is the different components and
you know that's why i'm saying to your
point
you know i'm always saying i'm not the
top virulgist of immunologist or a top
vaccinologist but you know it's so
multi-disciplinary i've learned to bring
these fields together even biophysics if
you don't understand the difference
between a polyvalent igm binding you
know antibody and a specific igm for a
specific antigen you know you will never
ever understand this right so so it's so
many different uh aspects that need to
be con to be put into consideration and
i'm always saying the my the value i'm
adding i hope i guess is putting the
different pieces of the puzzle that i
find in publications etc to put them
together and obviously you know today's
science is no longer capable that's why
i i love the thing you were saying at
the better way congress we need to
rebuild the science and to some extent
for these complex problems i think we
need to also have a different approach
to science in the sense that no thinking
in silos but a multi-disciplinary
approach well here's the funny thing i
mean i agree with what you said entirely
and i'm
frustrated to no end that the way
scientific education has evolved has
caused this obsession with
specialization yeah and right
and no doubt these things have their
place but the problem is
synthesis is the natural partner of
reductionism right and it is not
rewarded in our system so what you're
saying well i'm not a you know a great
this a great that but what i can do is
bring the things together well to me
all of my favorite evolutionary
biologists were involved in synthesis
that's what they were doing is taking
all of these
isolated things that don't seem to tell
a story and figuring out where you have
to stand in order to say ah
that's what this is right you know and
and that's really um
it's such a it's such a crucial part of
the process and what we've effectively
been watching i mean if we give the
benefit of the doubt and we say well
okay
they really screwed this up but it was
an honest error well if it was an honest
error it was an honest error created by
a committee of specialists where nobody
remembers how to put the whole thing
together right and it's it's it's tragic
and it's tragic at the level of like a
million american deaths you know it's
it's yeah unbelievable yeah i i fully
agree with you uh you know it's it's
it's just unbelievable that in you know
in
2022
where we have access to all this science
all these technologies you know all
these you know institutes put like
millions of of taxpayer dollars into it
and we are not we are not we we have no
clue how to tackle you know a a complex
health problem so that also means we
cannot give anything back to society
from all the the money that that got
invested right so all these publications
is in fact you know
they are essential they are important
but when you start to have publications
you know if it becomes
an objective in its own right i've
learned to use science as a tool
and if i don't see
any added value to the kind of problem
i'm studying i will not dig very deep
but if i think you know even a molecular
detail this could bring a piece of the
puzzle then i will take a deep dive
right and so it's a completely different
approach to you know to to to science
but you know you see it's needed in
situations like this the public health
authorities even the key opinion leaders
they don't know what's happening right
now will you do you agree they have no
clue where this thing is going right
they it's like the worst of all possible
worlds they don't know what's going on
and they have no idea a that they're in
the dark and b that there's another way
that wouldn't leave them in the dark
right
we've just lost the understanding of
this and everybody who does it all of
the generalists are driven out because
frankly you can't compete as a
generalist inside of the system so yes
it's a tragedy and when you think about
the immense costs of this i mean and
they're not even all quantifiable you
know this week at this conference
the one that's uh
i'm reminded
i'm reminded of how
frightening this is but
the gaslighting of the vaccine injured
i cannot think of anything more
diabolical in this right you injure
people
and then you tell them it's in their
head yeah
right and then you tell other people
that they're part of an anti-vaxx
movement you know we are living in a
surrealistic world right now it's uh
nothing nothing makes sense anymore of
any you know this is yeah
i'm always saying you know it's uh
it makes me and it takes something to
make me speechless but that that makes
me speechless right yeah i i find myself
also at a loss for words pretty
frequently
all right we have just paused to close
the curtains to prevent the darkness
from leaking in
um
uh i want to ask you though all right
we've looked at what you thought was
going to happen
there's been a surprise
the surprise is that the evolution of
greater infectivity did not
come with
greater virulence
uh so that's interesting
um
i guess we have to talk uh about
the question of ivermectin and its
dropping of uh effectiveness but before
yeah yeah well don't forget that
question yeah well maybe we should do
that and then let's return to
where where you think we are in the
pandemic and what you think okay
so uh and i'm not saying that you know
um
what i think is is right of course but
it might be it might point into the
right direction
which is that
right now we are facing a situation it
started already with delta but now it
you know it has moved you know to to an
extreme situation where the virus has
become resistant
to the vaccinal antibodies to the
potentially neutralizing antibodies
and there there are interesting studies
from professor fantini the university of
marseille who is a biochemist this has
been published
it's also in the document in the
manuscript that i gave you you know it's
uh
i'm referring to his publications
who has shown that
if the non if the sorry if the
neutralizing antibodies the potentially
neutralizing antibodies i should say are
no longer able to bind to the virus
that then non-neutralizing antibodies
can bind
so in a sense that it's always like this
if you induce antibodies
for example against the protein you may
have if that's pro if that protein is
responsible for example for
infectiousness you may use antibodies
that can you know neutralize the virus
but at the same time you are also
inducing antibodies we call them elisa
antibodies that are have no not
neutralizing capacity but that could
potentially bind
so now what he has found out is that
when the neutralizing capacity
dramatically diminishes
that a non-neutralizing antibodies can
bind to the spike protein and you could
imagine the following situation where
the neutralizing antibodies they bind to
the virus to the spike protein that you
have a kind of like a conformational
structural change
which prevents the non-neutralizing
antibodies from recognizing their
binding side because that also he has
been he has documented that the binding
site for the non-neutralizing antibodies
is not situated within the receptor
binding domain but it's situated within
the n-terminal domain that is one thing
what he has also shown is that this
domain is very conserved amongst all the
variants in contrast to the receptor
binding domain which we know is very
very valuable so
yeah the receptor binding domain has
been under intense pressure from
the vaccines yeah therefore we had
omicron 20 mutations or only in the in
the receptor binding domain right this
other domain is highly conserved which
you would expect because there's no
advantage to altering it presumably or
very little
yeah okay so go on
so what what what he has the most the
most spectacular thing he has
demonstrated or he has shown
is that
when this non-neutralizing antibodies
bind so preferably in people you know
who have antibodies that are no longer
functional so to say
then
the binding of these antibodies to the
spike will lead to an enhanced
infectiousness of the virus
yeah it's enhanced you know antibody
dependent but it's depending on the
non-utilizing antibodies uh enhancement
so now this is so we we need to unpack
that a little bit yeah so
the point is you've got
you've got a virus it has a molecular
structure that allows it to enter the
cell
you've got uh immunity generated by
these transfective agents
that is uh producing antibodies which
stick to this thing but the problem is
at this scale you can always get a
situation where what sticks to
the uh the protein is actually creating
a mechanism it's creating a new
mechanism potentially to get into the
cell or it's creating some change that
actually facilitates the entry well the
explanation is in fact and you know the
spike protein all this is dynamic right
yeah very often in biology things are
not static it's dynamic so the spike
protein has two different positions yeah
open and closed or up and down yeah so
this thing is going like this right
so
to bind to the ac2 receptors the spike
needs to be
in the open position and it can readily
bind but if it is sometimes closed you
know depending on the number of
statistically you know the contacts
sometimes it will go to the ac2 receptor
it's closed it will not bind yeah right
so now what the what the
non-neutralizing antibodies do by
binding
to the conserved domain within the
n-terminal domain it will force the
spike in the open position
and therefore it now becomes very
infectious what's have been shown in
peer-reviewed journals is that therefore
the susceptibility of the vaccines
to infection
you know is much higher than the
susceptibility of the non-vaccinated
people right right so that is something
very important to understand no
and i will come to the point of
eiffermectin but look i think this is
fascinating what we are seeing right now
if you think about this
the fact that it's not neutralizing
antibodies can now bind to the spike
all of a sudden what that means is that
the behavior of the virus the infectious
behavior of the virus is no longer
dependent only on the intrinsic
properties of the virus but it's to a
large extent
determined by the
the immune response
of the host the non-neutralizing
antibodies
we are seeing more and more that the
behavior of the virus is no longer
determined by seasonality
right yes look what is happening right
now i mean in my country over the last
four six weeks an enormous drought
unusual for belgium sunshine nice
temperature infections you know are all
over the place secondarily
we know that normally younger people are
better protected
against the infection than you know
older elderly people what you're seeing
now right now is that youngsters as well
young people
they get re-infected all the time so age
when you have these antibodies doesn't
seem to play a role anymore
you see what is happening that is
unprecedented we have never seen this
that the behavior now of the virus
unless you neutralize it but then it's
gone but that the behavior of the virus
the infectious behavior of the virus is
now largely determined
by the binding of the virus through this
non-nutrition it is not neutralizing
antibodies right
it disconnect the whole thing from
seasonality it disconnected from age et
cetera this is a rep because people say
yeah omicron decent isn't it no omicron
you know the behavior of omicron to a
large extent
determined by the immune response which
is anything but effective it's on the
contrary enhancing the infectiousness of
the virus so
um
you've got my evolutionary
brain racing because
in some sense if i understand what
you're saying correctly
the mass vaccination
of the population of planet earth
created
a synonymized
new species
i mean in effect what we had
was a human population with wildly
different susceptibilities to this virus
right so the virus was trying to solve
different problems and and also
depending on on the individual right you
know age and and etc we know that you
know people filterable orders were not
vulnerable etc right but what we
effectively did
was install the same port
on a huge population of people mass
vaccination yeah it does this yeah and
so by doing that then the point is now
the virus does not need to solve the
problem of
how do i infect old people and young
people that's a tough problem to solve
if those two systems work differently
because to work better in this one you
give up something in that one you're
harmonizing the whole thing right and by
synonymizing them by saying well you
know look old people and young people
they're going to have the same port if
you can figure out how to use that port
boom
that's exactly that's similar i have not
understood that before and i mean this
is not you know there is that's why i'm
saying you see this this pieces of the
puzzle
somebody demonstrates that it's
enhancing the infectiousness right
others demonstrate where exactly this is
binding others you know clinicians they
show for example that the susceptibility
of the vaccines is much higher to
infection than then we observe that you
know the behavior of the virus is no
longer bound to seasonality that it is
independent of age that becomes more and
more independent of age etc you see
these pieces of the puzzle and then you
fit all this you pack all these together
now what you're going to have to your
point
and i'm not saying that this is
this this applies this is the truth but
i think
that it started already to some extent
with delta which already was to some
extent more resistant you know to the
vaccinal antibodies now you have extreme
situation where in fact you are in an
artificial way because of the binding to
these non-neutralizing antibodies
pretty dramatically enhancing the
infectiousness of the virus so for me
you know that would automatically
require a higher dose
you know
of ivermectin not because the virus has
evolved but because now you have a new
component that synergizes with the
intrinsic infectious behavior of the
virus and that dramatically increases
the infection that's why we call it you
know antibody dependent enhancement of
infection right right so in effect
this is fascinating
a virus is a creature that has
surrendered its biology and gotten a
tremendous advantage by borrowing the
biology of its host
in this way it is borrowing the updated
biology
produced by the immune system right and
it is it is developing i mean this is
exactly what biology does this is
exactly why
you know why i have to shake my head at
people who thought they were going to
simply solve this pandemic with simple
tools they had no idea the complexity of
the thing they were interfacing yeah
well you know this is this is typically
biology you know everything is dynamic
the the virus is is
evolving the more you put pressure but
also the immune system we told about
training of the so that means if your
innate immunity
got not compromised
the unvaccinated you know they also get
more and more exposed to the virus but
they can drain their innate immunity so
it is it is like and that is why i
cannot understand why like public health
authorities they look at this oh look at
the hospitalization so they don't
understand that this is a dynamic right
that this is evolving and it will evolve
as long as we have not
achieved a new equilibrium a balance you
know if you have in after natural
pandemic you have a few waves and then
all of a sudden you know there is herd
immunity the population controls the
virus that is a kind of metastable
equilibrium because you know
people will age some people have
underlying diseases for example so
immunity may wane a little bit the
threshold as soon as the threat is a
very delicate balance as soon as the you
come get over the threshold you will
have a few people who get infection get
a disease that will immediately increase
the infectious pressure other people
will you know and then but still if
there's still sufficient hurt immunity
you can get this tie this thing again
under control that's why we we're
talking about an outbreak sometimes or a
small epidemic like we we we have with
flu but as long as you have not achieved
this kind of equilibrium between the
immunity of the population and the virus
you know this thing is is evolving and
you take a snapshot and you say
that is what you know that is what this
vaccine does it will it will you know uh
prevent hospitalizations and severe
disease we are also already seeing that
even that situation you know it was it
had a duration of at least several
months at the beginning it's now down to
a few weeks right and yeah so so
all right so several several things one
uh your your hypothesis on what happened
to the efficacy of ivermectin is pretty
interesting so yeah just recap well
that's my explanation but um
yeah but i like it and and your point if
i understand it
is that effectively the antibody
dependent enhancement has
increased the capacity of the virus to
infect people which is not a story that
involves ivermectin but what it means is
if you're dealing with a new pathogen
that has a new tool and that tool is one
that borrows from your immune system
when it derives from the system which is
you know the place where it replicates
it depends on the host right the point
is it's like
it's like a cat burglar
um arriving at a house where it knows
there's going to be a ladder yeah right
that's a cat burglar with some extra
capacity so you're going to need a
bigger better security system to defeat
that person and so the point is
ivermectin worked it still works
but you need a lot more of it to get the
same effect because the virus has
learned a few tricks along the way
because we taught it yeah we trained it
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely that's
very so when this entry into the cell
gets expedited it's logical that you
need to come
you know with a higher concentration at
the very beginning you cannot you know
if if the concentrate if
if if 20 particles enter at the same
time model is instead of five particles
the concentration at that
very surface of of of the susceptible
cell needs to be higher right that seems
very very logical to me but
i think there is no molecular proof of
this but there is uh yeah i mean at
least i think uh a hypothesis is uh
plausible for as long as there is you
know there is
some evidence that it is wrong right
yeah all right let me ask you another
question um
i wondered about and worried about what
would happen to something as useful as i
vermectin
and i'm troubled by the fact that you
need more of it although i'm heartened
to hear that that's not really a failure
of the drug that's actually on the virus
side absolutely that's what's going to
be absolutely yeah but here's the other
one i worry about
the virus did not transmit outdoors
essentially at all has it learned that
trick and if it hasn't learned that
trick is it going to learn that trick
because that will be a whole new
disaster for humanity to transmit
outdoors yeah
so um what do you beat exactly
the evidence was quite good that people
did not catch the infection outdoors and
the model that heather and i built which
i think is pretty pretty robust
is that
the
mode of transmission is highly dependent
on what we call the effective volume of
the space
right so in a car with the windows
closed it transmits pretty darn well
yeah right in the car with the window
open it's a lot slower to transmit and
you know the volume of a room and then
you get outside and effectively the
volume of the room is infinite and it
doesn't transmit
now
i'm
i can't think of a reason that this
virus shouldn't be able to if if humans
use the outside environment to evade the
virus i can't think of a reason that it
shouldn't be able to evolve the capacity
to transmit outdoors especially since
presumably its wild ancestor did yeah
but but does it really need to evolve to
acquire that capacity if you have
if if if you know that it all depends of
course on the viral load
you know
in the past for example before this
happened with the non-neutralizing
antibodies
you
maybe you know
you you
you required an inoculum or for example
just as an example 10 viral particles to
have we call this a take of the
infection
you know if you had for example you know
less than that fewer particles
you know you
they would
get onto your mucosa but you know there
would be no
virus i wouldn't have replication in my
exactly exactly but now if you have
these antibodies
right
it can make these antibodies of course
will bind before viral entry to this
virus and it makes the vital particles
more infectious
than five particles three particles
could be sufficient so that means it's
all a matter of concept we know this
very well
well certainly when we do experiments in
animals everything depends on the viral
load of course you need that many
particles otherwise you're not going to
be able to induce the
infection so now
i think that you know that people
especially if people are vaccinated who
become
very very susceptible
that
even if the virus gets significantly
diluted in an open air space
that there is still you know
a reasonable likelihood
that with 10 times
less particles on your mucosa that you
can still have a take of the infection
right this is exactly what i'm concerned
about i mean you've given me a mechanism
here but
i guess the point is the outside
environment has been
effectively infinite volume which means
you never rise above that infective
threshold yeah i don't know i don't know
but it's it's also you know if we are
outside and we are looking at pictures
on on on my
mobile phone
we are getting pretty close together we
are still outside with but you know that
could be sufficient but i don't think
people who are you know uh you know
walking some
somewhere in the woods you know i mean
that is very different but but there is
a situation where even outside you you
get pretty close uh together well that
was the funny thing about this virus at
the beginning was that we all thought
yeah outside you still need to distance
and all but then the evidence really
reflected the fact that nope
really outside was almost completely
protective
and you know and my thought was oh god
that's a that's an evolutionary
challenge that this thing can overcome
and anyway i'm wondering if it has
already if part of what we're seeing is
actually that it has learned this trick
um but anyway let's leave that aside i
think the final the final question that
we should address
is where do you think we are and what do
you think is coming
i think we are the virus is in the
process of
crossing
the valley of fitness
for
you know
overcoming
another pressure that we are putting now
fired and not neutralizing anybody's
because this story and this is another
piece of the puzzle
some scientists have been doing very
very interesting studies and have shown
that in fact
the non-neutralizing antibodies that we
were talking about and that are
responsible for enhancing the
infectiousness of the virus at the upper
respiratory tract and i i will explain
this in a moment but let me first
summarize this now these very same
antibodies
are responsible
for preventing severe disease in distant
organs
so what they have shown is that part of
the viral particles at the upper
respiratory tract
are taken by dendritic cells but they
are not internalized in the dendritic
cells they are absorbed at the surface
of the dendritic cells migratory you
know dendritic cells that migrate to
distant organs dendritic cells do that
one of the distant organs is the lower
respiratory tract but it could also be
delivered it could also be the digestive
tract for example
and they have shown that there is a
process that is called trans infection
and what is trans infection mean trans
infection is the transfer
of the virus that is absorbed on the
surface of the dendritic cell to a
susceptible alveolar epithelial cell
that process of trans infection
is inhibited they have shown this in
vitro therefore i'm saying these all
pieces of the puzzle right
this process of trans infection is
inhibited
by non-neutralizing antibodies
and that is due
to a conformational change that's that
prevents i'm in the manuscript that i
gave you i'm just
you know describing this in detail
but they use a conformational change
that makes it impossible for the virus
that is absorbed to the dendritic cell
to be transferred to the susceptible
cell because once it is transferred to
the susceptible cell
the susceptible cell gets infected and
will present the spike protein at the
surface and that will induce fusion
of the infected cell with a non-infected
cell
that will induce the synthetic i don't
know exactly how to pronounce this in
english the sensation you know what's
incision yeah yeah exactly and the
synthetic have been clearly correlated
with severe disease all patients dying
from severe disease you know you find
this in situ in the organs
so and that process is called not by me
but by this scientist transfusion
so you have the trans infection the
transfer from the the viral particles
absorbed at the surface of the dendritic
cell to the susceptible epithelial cell
that will then also infect other
non-infected cell through a process of
transfusion this is the s protein
that you know induces you know when it
gets presented
it is like you know it gets rearranged
so that it gets fusogenic capacity and
can make the cells fuse so that you have
a syntheticium
and that is what is
basically causing systemic and and and
severe disease so in other words the
non-neutralizing antibodies are
suppressing
or suppressing if you like virulence the
capacity to cause severe disease at this
moment in time yeah
so whereas at the first phase of the
pandemic
we had
neutralizing we had you know suppression
or we had immune pressure
on viral infectiousness
via the neutralizing antibodies
we have now immune suppression
on viral virulence
through the non-neutralizing antibodies
i can i can repeat it if you like well
i'm gonna need some help here first of
all there's some new things in here that
i just didn't even realize were on the
map so you're telling me that these uh
infected cells migrate internally to
vulnerable epithelial cells right these
are the dendritic cells right migratory
dendritic cells yeah to have you know
absorbed viral particles that they have
you know so when you say stroke
particles you're not talking about
virions you're talking about no i'm
talking about variance this is a synonym
you know vital particle and virion is
the same so they take in these they
don't take them in they absorb them at
the surface they are not internalizing i
see okay and so the difference right and
this is you you know
they have demonstrated this the
dendritic cells have c-type lictin
receptors at the surface obviously this
glycosylated viruses coronavirus you
know has glycans that stick to these
lectins and that is how you know they
absorb really to the surface
of the dendritic cell all right and then
they're being transported yeah they
migrate to these ethereal cells to
distant organs could be anything now the
virus
one of the things that's confusing about
this virus is it seems to um have such
high tropism for different tissues that
probably isn't really helping it
transmit which i take to be
a likely byproduct of a laboratory
origin that basically the rules that
usually keep a virus limited to
infecting tissues that help it transmit
are
largely alleviated by the laboratory
environment where the animal that it's
being passaged in for example doesn't
have normal constraints because
somebody's feeding it and it doesn't
have to walk around
um but
but in any case okay so it migrates to
these distant cells
distant organs you know
and one of these listed organs is of
course the lower respiratory tract body
but you you you you may of course know
that some people develop and you have
enteric problems digestive problems as a
result of coronavirus so it's not it's
not really strictly limited to the lower
respiratory tract right so people will
not have respiratory symptoms but they
will have diarrhea and and you know
things and spasm for example right yeah
which is interesting because it's not
transmitting this way as far as we know
which so that that's that's conspicuous
to me right this is well it's not
transmitted it will be shed but you know
it's it's a very fragile it's not like
enterovirus that is very resistant in in
the environment i mean i i i studied for
a long time environmental virology i
mean
coronaviruses is very fragile it cannot
really uh survive for a long time
certainly not in uh you know in in in
wastewater or in sludge or whatever
whereas with entry into enteroviruses
this is a primary source of of
contamination that's also why we you
know people are always saying we almost
eradicated polio to a large extent that
was due to water sanitation right and
and all these type of things right yeah
which is quite a can of worms there but
yeah
all right um so what does this mean uh
for
a what you expect the pandemic to do and
b how we will know if you know what's
the prediction of your hypothesis yeah
so what is what this means to me is that
we are currently
a very weird situation as i told you
already why where we have
a high level of infectivity of
infectiousness
but we have mild relatively mild disease
right
where uh we know that this mild disease
is not due to neutralizing into a
neutralization of the virus not due to
hurt immunity because on the on the
contrary we keep saying that we we have
high infection rates it's very
infectious so
what these vaccines are doing right now
is anything the generating herd immunity
yeah because herd immunity would mean
that you see a dramatic you know decline
of infection
seeing exactly the opposite so what we
are seeing is you know enhanced
infectiousness
but mild
mild symptoms
and if this is true what these people
suggest based on in vitro studies but i
must tell you brett these people have
done this in an and you know it's just a
coincidence that i know the group
because i uh you know they uh one of
these people that i know very well got a
a grant from the billionaire in the
gates foundation you know was working at
the foundation so i know
and um
so they have been using cells
that are
really simulating completely the
epithelial cells in a sense that their
ac2 expression is very low whereas we
know at the upper respiratory tract ac2
expression is pretty high and they also
explain why
indeed in order to infect nevertheless
cells that have low expression in ac2
they need some kind of help
it is you know
normally
this transfection that takes place is
helping infection because during this
when when the the virion gets
transfected you get
a rearrangement a structural
rearrangement of the spike protein which
makes it fusogenic and which enhances
despite the low concentration or the low
expression of ac2 you know the entry
into into the cell so i guess what i'm
saying is that now these
non-neutralizing antibodies are in fact
preventing preventing
you know this process from taking place
so in other words and we know i just
explained you they are binding to this
highly conserved antigenic site right
so to the same extent as the
neutralizing antibodies we're binding to
the receptor binding domain and exerting
pressure
you know on
viral infectiousness because this
receptor binding domain is the part that
you know enables spiral entry and hence
the infectiousness
the non-neutralizing antibodies by
binding to this you know antigenic site
within the n-terminal domain has been
shown that they bind are now like
exerting pressure on another
characteristic of the virus which is
viral virulence right and um
so there is no they don't prevent the
virus from replicating so
we still have high rates of transmission
higher than ever
so my
well guess is but of course i'm i'm i'm
only you know
sharing some fragments of the the puzzle
that i put together
but is that again the virus will be you
know will be capable of overcoming
the pressure but we know viruses can
overcome pressure that is exerted by by
antibodies i mean we have had the
example we have we have not learned from
the first phase of the pandemic because
what what the first phase of the
pandemic learned this is that
if we exert infectious pressure on a
characteristic of the sorry immune
pressure on the characteristic of the
virus without being capable of
preventing the transmission the fire you
know nature will do the natural
selection and will come will you know
give a competitive advantage to those
guys who are capable of overcoming this
right so and what is the result well we
have dominant propagation of a highly
infectious variant which is omicron
we have not learned that now you know
the
we are exerting pressure on the because
the virulence of omegran is lower is
lower than you know the virulence of
delta so
we have not learned that if we are now
exerting pressure and we know how this
comes is because there is pressure
you know of these non-neutralizing
antibodies by binding to this antigenic
site that is conserved in terminal
domain
you know we have not learned that this
immune pressure it's also an immune
pressure just on another domain is now
highly likely you know of
giving a competitive advantage to those
guys that will be able to overcome this
and i'm describing this in my manuscript
that this is i think it's highly likely
that this
will
will be possible by additional
glycosylation of the virus
i mean we can expand on this but it's
also very very
surprising to me that
if you read about glycosylated viruses
you know in every textbook of virology
will tell you that you know glycans are
so well suited to shield
antigenic domains from recognition from
antibodies and why is this well remember
this the the the viral membrane is in
fact part of the cellular membrane you
know with these viruses when the virus
is burning it gets enveloped by part of
the cellular membrane the cellular
membrane that is carrying cell glycans
right so the virus is carrying cell
glycogens that are not recognized per
definition by the immune system but they
can shield you know and a whole
antigenic domain from recognition right
and
so
that is what i think uh is is very
likely uh to happen that the virus will
overcome this and that we will end with
the virus that is not only high in
infectious but also virulent and that is
completely resistant to all the
any of the of the coffee 19 vaccines
so let me understand this
i see
why
this model predicts
omicron is not the
uh natural vaccine that many of us hoped
it might be
right that effectively it's highly
infectious it's going to give everybody
natural immunity and we can finally be
done with this
your model is saying that's not likely
i'm saying it's the case
for the unvaccinated because it's just
going to train better and better you
know the immune system of the
unvaccinated people right
and that is a very interesting comment
because i need to say
brett that
right now when people are saying you
know what there is still a number of
unvaccinated people that despite omicron
land in hospital
every medical doctor every virologist
every vaccinologist knows that if there
is one thing you cannot do with a live
attenuated vaccine so omicron
is still immunize vulnerable people
or people who are not in good health
because there is always a likelihood
that in those people the virus will
break through the despite the fact that
it's attenuated
so the people that know land in a
hospital with omicron or people that you
would never ever vaccinate with a live
attenuated vaccine yeah people with
underlying diseases with a weakened
innate immune system etc but for all the
others it's just you know
a training a training of the immune
system and you see the thousands the
vast majority of the population you know
unvaccinated you know is is is not
hospitalized right right yeah
so okay i i read you loud and clear now
um
you're saying that that model which many
of us discussed i certainly argue that
this is a possibility
um
is
logically correct but only functional in
those who have not been
trained by the transfection
[Music]
uh uh
i'm trying to avoid the word vaccine
because i know it's not right but the
the the covet 19 vaccines right so now
we've got two populations one of which
is carrying
effectively this synonymizing
port i described it as before i'm just
speaking metaphorically
and then the unvaccinated population is
still highly variable and also is being
trained by omicron uh to be better and
better at fighting off closely related
uh coronaviruses yeah there is one
important thing that i need to tell you
yeah that is that i told you that a
non-neutralizing antibodies are directed
against an antigenic site within the
n-terminal domain that is very conserved
now
so
people got vaccinated with the wuham
strain
well we know what the s protein you know
corresponding to the wuhan lineage
so
the receptor binding domain of of this
one so so
that means that people have been primed
their immune system has been primed to
recognize the receptor binding domain of
the one as well as the n-terminal domain
right
so now you come back
with a virus
omicron
which has an in-terminal domain it's in
fact the antigenic site within the
n-terminal domain but i'm going to keep
it simple the n-terminal domain so to
say that it's very concerning conserve
so the same as wilhelm
other is variable yeah
so antigenic sin
tells you that when you have primed with
an antigen and you come back with the
same antigen
that those antibodies will go through
the roof
right so so the non-neutralizing
antibodies and you don't need an
additional omicron vaccine simply by the
circulation
and
people are highly susceptible to
vaccines
they get their non-neutralizing
antibodies
boosted like hell
for the none for the for for the part of
omicron that the part of the virus that
has changed it's the first priming
because in wuhan the receptor binding
domain was completely different
right so before new antibodies can
develop against a part of the virus that
has been changed dramatically changed
namely the receptor binding domain that
will take time before that can happen
the non-neutralizing antibodies in no
time will go through the roof enhance
the infection you see what i'm saying i
think if you take away
if you take away this resistance to the
non-neutralizing antibodies then the
enhanced infectiousness will
automatically result in enhanced disease
so if i understand you correctly what
you're saying is
you've got this n-terminal domain which
is highly conserved and well it's a part
it's an it's a part the part that is
recognized by the non-neutralizing
antibodies is highly conserved and is
situated has been well described within
the in terminal domain okay
so what that does is it is basically a
signal to the immune system that
activates
that fraction which was trained at the
same time and so trained on the wuhan s
protein
uh the receptor binding domain which is
now changed so effectively this is
tailor-made to trigger the immune system
to deploy an ineffective response which
now enhances the capacity of the virus
to infect is that what you're saying
yeah
it's just that we in that case we we
don't talk that much about the training
we we would rather say has induced
memory because it's about specifically
not neutralizing antibodies or still
specific and acquired antibodies but
that's a detail yeah i'm i'm speaking uh
colloquially yeah
so that's uh that sounds like a recipe
for um
[Music]
a
a new phase of this pandemic
especially in light of the fact that it
predicts that there are two populations
those who have been transfected with
these so-called vaccines and those who
haven't who are going to have exactly
inverse
response
to the future variants and
so in any case one i would just say
that's
um frightening yeah it is it's also
proper scientific form it's a hypothesis
it's delivered with a prediction we can
know whether it's right you know and as
with your initial predictions might be
that there's a nuance where the model is
mostly correct and then something
surprising
interfaces you know a lot of things
could happen but anyway we at least you
know
i think the thing is
very troubling to hear you say that
because i heard you say your predictions
before and although the world did not
unfold exactly as you predicted it was a
lot closer to what you predicted than
what anybody else predicted well it
occurs in two phases right this is and
if you think about this if you think
about this we got variants that were
more and more infectious
at a certain point the virus become
became resistant to the neutralizing
antibodies
that enabled the virus that enabled the
virus to exert pressure on viral
virulence
because as long as you don't have
the non-neutralizing antibodies that
take over you cannot exert pressure on
virulence
so you have more and more infectious
virus then all of a sudden
you know the virus becomes resistant the
non-neutralizing antibodies take over
and those now start to exhort exert
immune pressure on viral virulence and
what i'm saying it is that
whereas at the beginning of the pandemic
the immune pressure
was gradually increasing because there
was like one variation or two or two or
three variations within the receptor
binding domain now we are talking about
boosting of non-neutralizing antibodies
so all of a sudden in a large vast
majority of the population in highly
vaccinated countries we are having a
huge immune pressure right by this boost
right
and we have been
doing mass vaccination so it's in highly
vaccinated countries the majority of the
population right because it's always the
population that exerts the immune
pressure when we agree on that one
single individual cannot do this right
so
i guess what i'm saying is that whereas
you could think of the evolution of the
virus
you know taking a more or less linear
course at the beginning of the pandemic
that what we are seeing right now is
like you know an exponential thing and
it's very very
strange that now for the first time
within one of these families
of ovarians the omicron even within this
family we have now
more infectious sub-variants to an
extent that the who has now decided that
you know to be a 4 or ba-5 we need to
consider them in their own right as a
variant of concern yeah that actually
begins to feel
like
um
an adaptive radiation
right and so i may be stretching a
little far here
but my sense uh is that when we see an
adaptive radiation basically we see a
branch of the evolutionary tree that
suddenly sprouts a wide diversity
because we haven't seen this with delta
we have not seen this with gamma right
exactly and so my my point is that
actually there's something selectively
going on that's different and what i
would argue it's at least consistent
with your model that what's happened is
we've crossed a threshold where the
opportunity basically the reward for
experimenting has gone up
and therefore the virus is now
experimenting in effect with different
ways of being so another explanation
could be that
the binding
of the non-neutralizing antibodies to
the antigenic site is still improving
[Music]
but you know i mean
that can still go on for some time but
you know the pressure is
i think enormous and that's why i'm
saying it's the value of fitness you
know this from evolution right you have
the the selection but then the virus
need to be to become dominant right it
needs to cross this valley to become
more and fitter and fitter
and
yeah
so so the situation that we are in right
now
i think that is the summary at least of
my
analysis is completely unstable
is unstable the virus has not reached
the equilibrium right yes we have we
have not reached equilibrium and i think
one way of interpreting what you have
delivered so far
is that we have prevented ourselves from
reaching an equilibrium that we would
have gotten to and it might have been
very
painful we might have arrived there at
an unacceptable cost but we would have
arrived there and we're not arriving
there at all and we've got to ask
ourselves the question
how long are we going to keep
interfering before we realize we're
creating our own problem but you know
the problem is that we have now
a load
a highly infectious virus to circulate
and that that in its own right is
boosting people all the time
we cannot you know we cannot
take this away right that is where i'm
saying if we are not because if you
think about this if you think about this
if the infection rate rises in the
population
then of course you are going to have the
prevalence the prevalence in the
population
of elevated
titus of non-neutralizing antibodies is
going to to increase
that is going to increase the immune
pressure on the whole thing
right the more immune pressure the
higher the infection rate so both are
interconnected so what can you do
mankind
can
diminish the infectious pressure
you know
massive mass antiviral campaigns for
example right
but
if we don't do anything about this the
other thing is to diminish the immune
pressure now who is exerting this immune
pressure it's not the non-vaccinated
population
it's a vaccination
so if you want to achieve this
equilibrium and you don't play want to
play
with the infection rate you don't want
to diminish this what you're going to
get is that immune pressure need to
diminish to rupture this vicious circle
but that means that it's a population
that is exerting that immune pressure
you know that needs to be
reduced
in order to get your
60 70 percent of earth immunity because
now the earth immunity is like the
unvaccinated let's say 10
if you want to increase this
right if you're going to diminish
the contribution of the of the
vaccinated population then you can
increase this to like 60 or 70 percent
the other way to increase is increase it
but theoretical is a baby boom or it's
massive immigration from poorly
vaccinated countries or it is you know
the ultimate solution would be a vaccine
that prevents transmit that blocks the
transmission that induces sterilizing
immunity no we don't have this right now
frankly speaking i don't know about any
other solution right
dude
yeah that's very troubling so it's very
troubling yeah i mean i i that's why i i
told i told uh
you know dell victory do you really want
me to convey this kind of message
to your audience because you know it's
it's not good news but you know be happy
you know this as an evolutionary
biologist that this type of balance
between
a pathogen and an immune system has been
shaped over thousands of years to
evolution through like natural selection
all these type of things what we have
done here literally is we have
thrown a bombshell
on this thing you know on this delicate
balance that has been established for
many many many years right
and
and then we we we would would we expect
that this thing is just going to die out
it's not going to have consequences or
micronization it's the end of the
pandemic phase as our friend fauci is
saying you know how can you ever end the
pandemic without cutting dramatically
the infection rate what you are seeing
right now is exactly the opposite right
right and i don't know how we got here i
think it was a combination of
hubris
some kind of wishful thinking the belief
that we were entitled to come up with a
miraculous vaccine very quickly narrow
against his stupidity arrogance and
stupidity and greed there's also an
element of this in which they don't feel
the pain because they're financially
winning as they deliver us these feeble
products i agree i agree um all right
well this has been
um quite a discussion it's certainly
unnerving
um if you had to give advice to the
world what's the next thing
presumably your advice is stop the
vaccination campaign has already been my
advice almost like a year ago the whole
time yep yeah and i think i think your
view has been borne out um
obviously
you would favor uh the widespread
careful use of
uh repurposed drugs that work yeah
absolutely yeah absolutely i don't see
any other solution and if that's not
going to happen
i can only advise people who are
potentially vulnerable we know
which part of the population we are
talking about
as we were saying regardless of age
regardless of age this time yeah
to get
access to antivirus to protect
themselves right at an individual basis
uh i i don't have a very good feeling
with this because if this whole
operation is not coordinated because
every individual will need to care for
himself or herself
then
i do not rule out that we may even start
to
you know
face problems with with with his
antiviral drugs
in terms of
resistance you know the higher
concentration we were talking about has
nothing to do with that right
but if now people are going to take this
on an irregular basis or they are just
going to take it prophylactically you
know we heard this also during the
congress say you know i i went to the
workshop the first uh the first day i
don't know whether you attended this
where people say oh can you take this
prophylactically etc
we know what happens if you know if
people or if we administer to animals
you know prophylactically uh
antibiotics for example i mean it's uh
some drugs
yeah but yeah so i'm not saying it's
going to happen but i i don't have a
good feeling it's saying you know
everybody can get this over the counter
or everybody should you should use this
and and and you know you use it the way
you think it's it's good for you etc
well this is a great reason not to have
um
sabotage the credibility of the entire
medical establishment simultaneously
because what we really need
is to have the doctors on board with a
proper
regulated campaign that uses these
antivirals in the way that they should
that will not exert this kind of
selective pressure where suddenly we'll
lose the few tools that actually work
right that would be a disaster
all right well this has been a great
discussion i really appreciate you
having it with us and i really
appreciate
that you are
doing this work because you know those
of us who have been paying attention
know
that um
it has largely been a thankless task
yeah nobody wants to hear what you're
trying to tell them i know i know and uh
anyway i appreciate that you're doing it
and um and uh at least know that there
are some of us out there listening and
that we've gotten a lot from it well
that that's what i uh appreciate also
that you are doing is uh is is listening
to because you are you know one of the
few people also is deeply involved in
this and has of course the capacity on
your background to grasp uh to a large
extent you know the kind of elements
that i'm bringing to the table
uh
because yeah it's of course
very important it would be an ideal
situation if if more and more scientists
would you know
try to understand and try to think about
the consequences because even if you
know only part of what i'm saying would
come out it's still going to be
catastrophic right
and and and if you know even a
hypothesis that i think if you will read
the manuscript i'm i'm really happy to
hear you know any comments and and where
you think it is it's not well documented
or or but um
i think i've put a lot of work in this
to make this as scientific as possible
and if that is indeed the case i cannot
understand that we can simply put this
aside and say yeah you know there is no
race pledges continue right i mean that
is that is just uh you can debate about
a certain elements and likelihoods but
uh
if a hypothesis is is i think relatively
well
documented and
arguments are
you know scientifically reasonable just
to put everything aside and you know
completely ignore this i mean if you
think about the consequences at the
population level and at an individual
level right
i mean it's it's it's just it's just
unbelievable that uh
we yeah and and that that
we would force you know
whole populations to go through this
kind of drama right it's it's crazy i
will actually go one step further than
you here
um i often
i'm often surprised at how important the
philosophy of science is in
understanding science itself and in this
case you um
what you've got is
a past prediction that is
highly accurate
right
um you predicted
a pandemic of variance
yeah everyone knows that we are now
living a pandemic of variance so the
point is when somebody gets something
like that right then the answer is what
do they know that i don't know
right they should be coming to you now
and saying what did you know that we
don't know teach us that and to the
extent that they're not that is on them
um but
somehow we got to get control of the
system and we've got to restore reason
to it because this is now a massive
self-inflicted wound yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely yeah well as i was
um telling you uh brit i mean it makes
me speechless and when i'm talking
these things you know as
a human being i cannot believe
that i'm telling this type of stuff
but when i take a deep dive in the
science as i'm something you know i get
immersed by and i say well this is
so compelling
you know i i must share this with with
somebody at least right so it's it's
it's it's a very strange feeling right
uh
yeah
anyway
anyway well um yeah
it's weird i don't believe in being
called in the religious sense of the
term but there's some analog to it and i
think you've been called and i i
appreciate that you're shouldering the
burden
okay all right thank you
thank you
[Music]